hey i'm dale this is making with ml and
today you're going to build a machine
learning model
right here right now and in under 10
minutes i'm going to show you how to use
a tool called teachable machines to
train a model from your browser
really fast let's get to it so today i
thought it would be fun to train a model
that recognizes letters that i make with
my body
like a b c
but for starters i'm just going to train
the model to recognize the letters ymca
i'm going to use tool machines to do
this it's one of the coolest ml tools
out there because it allows you to train
a model
that's for photos or for audio or pose
without writing any code and it runs
straight in your browser
all you need to get started is a
computer with webcam so first go to
teachablemachine.withgoogle.com and
click get started
from here you can see there are three
different types of models you can train
image audio and pose but we'll make a
pose project
now the idea with machine learning is to
train a computer to find patterns in
data so step one is to collect training
data
in the ui you can collect training data
right from your webcam so i'm going to
create a bunch of examples of me
making the letter y with my body first
create a new class with whatever you
want to detect in this case the letter y
so as you can see the ui is already
detecting my pose and my facial
expressions using a pre-trained model
but what i really wanted to do is
recognize the letters that i'm making
so let's take some example pictures you
want to take pictures of yourself from
lots of different angles and distance
from the camera which will prevent the
model from overfitting on features about
the room or the camera angles
now i'll collect some data for m c
and a once you're done collecting data
click
train model when you hit this button
tensorflow.js actually trains a new
neural network from data right in your
browser so do not close this window
your computer is doing a lot of work
under the hood click advanced and under
the hood to learn more about how it
works
once your model is done training you can
try it out right here in the browser
it works the best thing about teachable
machines is that it's really easy to
export your model
you can either download it as a
tensorflow model file or
you can have tutorial machines hosted
for you and they even give you this nice
shareable link
plus there's a nice javascript code
sample that you can use to easily add
the model to your web app
if you want to learn about all of my
favorite easy to use machine learning
tools check out my blog below
that's it for now and if you liked what
you saw today tell me what you want me
to build in the comments
until then see you next time